the youthful the youthful perspective on
the future the present perspective on
the future and the future mature
perspective on the future I'd like to
try and bring all those three tenses
together in one identity tonight and you
could say that the port in many ways
looks at what I call the conversational
nature of reality and you ask yourself
what is the conversational nature of
reality the conversational nature nature
of reality is the fact that whatever you
desire of the world whatever you desire
of your partner in a marriage or love
relationship whatever you desire of your
children whatever you desire of the
people who work for you or with you or
your world will not happen exactly as
you would like it to happen
yeah but equally whatever the world
desires of us whatever our partner our
child our colleague our industry our
future demands of us will also not
happen and what actually happens is this
frontier between what you think is you
and what you think is not you and this
frontier of actual meeting between what
we call itself and what we call the
world is the only place actually where
things are real but it's quite
astonishing how little time we spend at
this conversational frontier and not
abstracted away from it in one strategy
or another I was I was coming through
immigration which is quite a dramatic
border at the moment into the US last
year and you know you get off an
international flight across the Atlantic
you're not in the best place you're not
at your most spiritually mature you're
quite impatient with the rest of
humanity in fact so that when you get up
to immigration with your shirt collar
out and the day's growth of beard and
you you have very little patience that
the immigration officer said looked at
my passport and they said what do you do
mr. white I said I work with the
conversational nature of reality and he
leaned forward over his podium and he
said I needed you last night and I said
I'm sorry my powers as a poet and
philosopher only go so far I'm not sure
I can but before we knew it we were into
a conversation about his marriage here
he was in his uniform and the
interesting thing was he was looking up
and down the row of officers to make
sure his supervisor didn't see that he
was having a real conversation but all
of us live at this conversational
frontier with the future I'd like to put
you in the shoes of my Irish niece
Marlene McCormack standing on a cliff
edge on the western coast of Spain
overlooking the broad Atlantic 23 years
old she's just walked 500 miles from san
jaun pierre de pau on the french side of
the pyrenees all the way across northern
spain on this very famous old and
contemporary pilgrimage called the
Camino de Santiago de Compostella the
path to Santiago of copper Compostela
and when you get to when you get to
Santiago actually it can be something of
an anti-climax because there are a
hundred thousand people living there who
are not necessarily applauding you as
you're coming into town and ten thousand
of them are trying to sell you a memento
of your journey but you do have the
possibility of going on for three more
days to this place where Marlene stood
called in Spanish finis terrae in
English sinister from the Latin meaning
the ends of the earth the place where
ground turns to ocean the place where
your present turns into the future and
Marlene had walked this way she just
cried
rated as a 23 year old from the
University of Sligo with a degree in
Irish drama and she said to me I don't
think the major cooperation to the world
will be knocking on my door I said
listen I've worked in corporations all
over the world for decades a degree in
drama is what would most prepare you for
the adult corporate world but she said
I'm not interested in that anyway I want
I don't want to teach drama I want to
become a dramatist I want to write plays
so I walked the Camino in order to give
myself some courage in order to walk
into my future and I said what was the
most powerful moment you had on the
whole Camino the very most powerful
moment and she said I had many powerful
moments but you know the most powerful
moment was post Camino was that three
days you go on from Santiago and come to
this cliff edge and you go through three
rituals the first ritual is to eat at a
pass plate of scallops or if you're
vegetarian to contemplate the scallop
shell because the scallop shell has been
the icon and badge of your walk and
every arrow that you have seen along
that way has been pointing underneath a
scallop shell so really this first
ritual is saying how did you get to this
place how did you follow the path to get
here how do you hold the conversation of
life when you feel unbearable it when
you left yourself how do you hold the
conversation of life that brings you to
this place and the second ritual is that
you burn something that you've brought I
said what did you burn Marling she said
I I burned a letter in two postcards I
said astonishing 23 years old and you
have paper I can't believe it you know
I'm sure there's a Camino app where you
can just delete a traumatic text you
know and it will engage the flashlight
imbue it with color and disappear in it
in a firework of flames you know but you
burn you either bring a letter or you
write one there and you burn
and of course we know intuitively what's
on the what is on those letters and
postcards it's a form of affection and
love that is now no longer extension and
then the third ritual between all these
fires are large piles of clothes and you
leave an item of clothing that has
helped you to get to this place and I
said to Marlon what did you leave at the
Clifford she said I left my boots the
very things that I walked in actually
they were beautiful boots I love those
boots but they were finished after seven
weeks of walking so I walked away in my
trainers but I left my boots sir she
said it was really incredible the most
powerful moment was the Sun was going
down but the full moon was coming up
behind me and the full moon was
illuminated by the dying Sun in such a
powerful way that even after the Sun had
dropped below the horizon the moon could
still see that Sun and I had a moon
shadow and I was looking at my moon
shadow walking across the Atlantic
across this ocean now and I thought oh
that's my new self going into the future
but suddenly I realized the Sun was
falling further the moon was losing its
reflection and my shadow was
disappearing the most powerful moment I
had on the whole Camino was when I
realized I myself had to walk across
that unknown sea into my future while I
was so taken by this story I wrote this
piece for her we were driving at the
time we got home i sat on the couch I
wrote I wrote until 2:00 in the morning
everyone had gone to bed and I gave it
to Marlene at breakfast time and it's
called Finisterre for marlene mccormick
the road in the end the road in the end
taking the path the son had taken the
road in the end taking the path at son
the son had taken into the western sea
the road in the end
taking the path the Sun had taken into
the western sea and the moon the moon
rising behind you as you stood where
ground turned to ocean no way to your
future now no way to your future now
accept the way your shadow could take
walking before you across water going
where shadows go no way to make sense of
a world that wouldn't let you pass
except to call an end to the way you had
come to take out each letter you had
brought and light their illumine corners
and to read them as they drifted on the
late Western light to empty your bags to
empty your bags
to sort this and to leave that to sort
this and to leave that to promise what
you needed to promise all along to
promise what you needed to promise all
along and to abandon the shoes that
brought you here right at the water's
edge not because you had given up not
because you had given up but because now
you would find a different way to tread
and because through it all part of you
would still walk on no matter how over
the waves Finisterre for marlene
mcCormick
[Music]
who has already had her third play
performed in off off off off Broadway in
Dublin but she's on her way yeah this is
this is the last piece this is about the
supposed arrival at the the sum of all
of our endeavors yeah in Santiago itself
it could be Santiago it could be Mecca
it could be Varanasi it could be Kyoto
it could be that threshold you've set
for yourself now the disturbing approach
to the consummation of all your goals
and one of the one of the difficulties
about walking into your life about
coming into this body into this world
fully is you start to realize that you
have manufactured three abiding
illusions that the rest of humanity are
shared with you since the beginning of
time and the first illusion is that you
can somehow construct a life in which
you are not vulnerable now you can
somehow be immune to all of the
difficulties and ill health and losses
that humanity has been subject to since
the beginning of time if we look out at
the natural world there's no part of
that world that doesn't go through
cycles of first incipient soar
hiddenness but then growth fullness but
then a beautiful to begin with
disappearance and then a very austere
full disappearance so we look at that we
said that's beautiful but can I just
have the first half of the equation
please here and when the disappearance
is happening I'll close my eyes and wait
for the new cycle to come around which
means most human beings are at war with
reality 50% of the time the mature
identity is able to live in the full
cycle yeah
the second illusion is I can construct a
life in which I will not have my heart
broken
romance is the first place we start to
do it when you're at the beginning of a
new romance a new marriage you say I
have found the person who will not break
my heart I'm sorry
you have chosen them out unconsciously
for that exact core competency yeah they
will break your heart
why because you care about them yeah you
look at parenting yeah
parenting I will be the perfect mother
and father your children will break your
heart and they don't even have to do
anything spectacular or dramatic but
usually they do do something special to
break your heart yeah and then they live
with you as spies and saboteurs for
years watching your every psychological
move and spotting your every weakness
and one day when they're about 14 years
old with your back turn to them in the
kitchen while you're making something
for them
the psychological stiletto goes in
[Laughter]
and you say how did you know exactly
where to place a chana and they say I've
been watching you for good and then we
hope that our armored professional
personalities will prevent us from
having our heart broken in work but if
you're sincere about your work it should
break your heart you should get to
thresholds where you do not know how to
proceed you do not how to know how to
get from here to there and what does
that do it puts you into a proper
relationship with reality why because
you have to ask for help
heartbreak the own we don't have a
choice about heartbreak we only have a
choice of having having our hearts
broken over people and things and
projects that we deeply care about and
the last illusion is I can somehow plan
enough and arrange things that I will be
able to see the path to the end right
from where I'm standing right to the
horizon yeah but when you think about it
the only environment in where in which
that would be true would be a flat
desert empty of any other life yeah but
even in a flat desert the curvature of
the earth would take the path away from
you so no you see the path and then you
don't and then you see it again so this
is Santiago the supposed arrival which
is a kind of return to the beginning all
at the same time we have this experience
you know of the journey which is in all
of our great spiritual traditions of
pill dementia but just by actually
standing in the ground of your life
fully not trying to abstract yourself
into a strategic future that fact
just an escape from present heartbreaker
the ability to stand in the ground of
your life and to look at the horizon
that is pulling you in that moment you
are the whole journey you are the whole
conversation Santiago the road scene
then not seen the road scene they're not
seeing the hillside hiding then
revealing the way you should take the
road scene then not seeing the hillside
hiding then revealing the way you should
take the road dropping away from you as
if leaving you to walk on thin air then
catching you catching you holding you up
when you thought you would fall catching
you holding you out when you thought you
would fall and the way forward the way
forward always in the end the way that
you came the way forward always in the
end the way that you came the way that
you followed the way that carried you
into your future that brought you to
this place that brought you to this
place no matter that it sometimes had to
take your promise from you no matter
that it always had to break your heart
along the way the sense the sense of
having walked from deep inside yourself
out into the revelation to have risked
yourself for something that seemed to
stand both inside you and far beyond you
and that called you back in the end to
the only road you could follow walking
as you did in your rags of love walking
as you did in your rags of love and
speaking in the voice that by night
became a prayer for safe arrival so that
one day one day you realized that what
you wanted
had actually already happened one day
you realized that what you wanted had
actually already happened and long ago
and in the dwelling place in which
you lived before you began and that and
that every step along the way every step
along the way you had carried the heart
and the mind and the promise that first
set you off and then drew you on and
that and that you were more marvelous in
your simple wish to find a way you were
more marvelous in your simple wish to
find a way than the gilded rules of any
destination you could reach you were
more marvelous in that simple wish to
find a way than the gilded grooves of
any destination you could reach as if
all along you had thought the end point
might be a city with golden domes and
cheering crowds and turning the corner
at what you thought was the end of the
road you found just a simple reflection
and a clear revelation beneath the face
looking back and beneath it another
invitation all in one glimpse all in one
glimpse like a person like a person or a
place
you had sought forever like a person or
a place you had sought forever like a
bold field of freedom that beckoned you
beyond like another life like another
life and the road the road still
stretching on
[Music]
very much thank you very kindly